-Happy Friday, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're in here.
We're safe. We're cozy.
That's right, the East Coast
is currently getting hit
by a bomb cyclone
that's going to dump anywhere
from 1 to 2 feet of snow.
[ Laughter ]
For parents, that means
20 inches of snow outside
and 20 hours of "Encanto"
inside.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the blizzard is on track
to be so bad,
Boston could be in
for one of its biggest
snowstorms ever.
[ Audience oohs ]
Don't worry -- the plows
have been instructed
to focus on Boston's
most essential places --
schools, hospitals,
and Dunkin' Donuts.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the weather in Boston is so bad,
Bill Belichick has switched
from his short-sleeve
ripped sweatshirt
to his long-sleeve
ripped sweatshirt.
[ Laughter ]
Now, that's cold.
-Cold.
-That's cold.
Well, here's some wild news.
Today, President Biden
went to Pittsburgh.
Did you guys hear about this?
Went to Pittsburgh
to talk about the need
for his infrastructure bill.
And thankfully,
nobody was seriously injured,
but just hours
before his arrival,
a bridge in Pittsburgh
actually collapsed.
[ Audience gasps ]
Biden didn't even give
his speech.
He just stuck his head out his
car window and go, "Told ya!"
[ Laughter ]
And it turns out,
back in 2019,
the bridge was given
a condition rating of "poor."
First of all,
when it comes to bridges,
shouldn't it just be more of
a pass/fail type of deal?
[ Laughter ]
It's either on or it's off,
you know?
Well, this is fun.
Today, the Bidens announced
a new addition to the family,
a 2-year-old tabby cat
named Willow.
[ Audience aws ]
Yeah, the president is thrilled
to have a cat.
Now he can finally say
he got something fixed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Clap if you feel like --
It keeps you warm
if you clap, yeah.
I think it's going to be fun
when the cat walks across
Biden's keyboard
and it sets off war with Russia.
[ Laughter ]
Right now, the White House staff
is amusing the cat
with the same laser pointer they
used to keep Trump entertained.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating Trump ] "It was over
there. No, it's over there.
No, it's on that wall."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Normal voice ]
Biden's been busy this week.
Ukraine's President called
and told him
to calm down the messaging about
a potential Russian invasion
because it's making people
panic.
Yeah, we all know
nothing calms people down more
than saying, "Calm down."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Ukraine's President said
there's no reason to panic.
Then he was like,
"Now, if you need me,
I'll be fleeing to Poland."
[ Laughter ]
Well, Biden isn't the only
world leader
trying to find a solution to
the Russia-Ukraine crisis.
Today, French President
Emmanuel Macron
spoke on the phone
with Vladimir Putin.
Macron was like, "If you invade,
France will have to
get involved."
And Putin was like, "No,
seriously, why did you call?"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, listen to this.
I heard that New Hampshire
is going to start
selling rapid COVID tests
at liquor stores.
You'll know your uncle's
got a problem when he's like,
[ Slurred ] "I tested negative
75 times this week.
[ Laughter ]
75. Negative."
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Normal voice ]
And finally, a company
is recalling
thousands of chainsaws
because they can spontaneously
start running
after being switched off.
If there's one word
you don't want
to describe your chainsaw,
it's "spontaneous."
We have a great show.